so is prince charles ready to be king or
is this the beginning potentially of the
end of the british monarchy this is the
debate raging everywhere at the moment
joining me now to discuss it author and
journalist tony parsons political
activist case kate smithway welcome to
both of you thank you thank you kate let
me start with you we just had this story
and put it into perspective the queen
one of the all-time great monarchs
indisputably if you're ranking monarchs
she'd be right up there to me number one
but you know there's some other
compelling candidates you don't like the
concept of the monarchy right yeah it's
not like i don't i don't dislike that
elderly lady that would be ridiculous um
but i just think it's 2022 and the time
for having a monarchy was a few
centuries back and i think if anything
has shown that it's the recent caribbean
tour isn't it i mean how patronizing to
have the british royal family wandering
around the caribbean expecting people to
bow and scrape in front of them and i
think brilliant that people all across
the caribbean kicked back and said hold
on a minute do you not understand the
history and what this represents and i
think that the history of what the
monarchy represents is no less of an
issue in this country where you know the
working classes the proletariat have
been continuously oppressed by this
structure of the class system and the
monarchy at the top of it and i think
it's about time that we all run and
interestingly you know here i am you're
asking my opinion about the monarchy
here's how the monarchy works we that
you know we are we are the we are the
riffraff we are the bottom of the pile
we don't get an opinion if you want an
opinion on who should be monarch then
you like me want a republican oh you're
getting an opinion right now tony passes
but that's my point aid you identify as
riffraff
nobody knows the working-class mentality
of this country better than you do
you've written about it for decades
what do you think about that i mean
there are young people there's no
unquestionably there are young people a
lot of them fueled by meghan markle's
claims of racism and so on at the palace
and so on who have turned against the
idea of a monarchy um i think the
working class have always seemed quite
keen on the monarchy to me when i was um
a young punk in 1977 hanging out with
the sex pistols it was um the working
class who wanted to give us a good kick
in disrespecting the queen um i think
that the um the queen with her 70-year
reign has secured the monarchy for the
next hundred years or so i don't think
there's any i don't think anybody alive
in this country today will live in a
republic she's secure she's made the
case for the monarchy and she's an
exceptional woman and circumstances were
exceptional she was so young when she
came to the throne she's lived such a
long time and i think that combination
of stamina and substance and i think
she's got better and i think she's got
better with age since um she jumped out
of a helicopter before the 2012
london olympics
through to the um the height of the
pandemic the 75-year anniversary she was
i mean i know the argument they're not
elected people but i look at our elected
officials i look at boris johnson kia
stammer squabbling over who may have
broken more lockdown rules who may have
betrayed the trust of the people more
and you look at the queen who for 70
years has held that trust has kept our
respect i'm not sure that that's always
been the case there's definitely been
times when i've been like really she's
meeting the leaders of saudi arabia has
she looked at the amnesty international
reports on their human rights record
there are definitely times when i've
been like actually i'm not totally sure
that she's doing the right thing or
shaking hands with the right people but
the fact that there are elected
officials who are terrible and i'm in no
disagreement with you that there's no
shortage of those um i don't think that
the answer is well let's just decide
that democracy doesn't work and throw
out it's very ironic actually to have
seen prince charles today saying this
government her majesty's government will
uphold democracy around the world and
you're like but you're the embodiment of
us not having yeah but in a way in a way
tony parsons they they're figure heads
above our democratic system they're not
elected but they do pay for themselves i
always make this argument to american
friends you say well they must cost a
fortune well they do but they also get
it back from the huge tourism they
attract not least from the united states
the queen has been there for 14 prime
ministers seen and come and seen seen
him go and even prime ministers that won
three general elections like thatcher or
blair they seem like footnotes in that
70 year reign and i think the fact that
she's she i mean i i understand what
kate's saying about shaking the hands
with um saudi arabians but one of the
great things about her is she's got this
genius for having the poker face that
she hasn't picked and choose to walk you
know we don't fancy your human rights
record she's met the lot she's met
oh yeah the lost no she's not i i think
most most british people would would
prefer a monarch that can meet any head
of stay in any dictator rather than
rather than pick and choose about you
know because then that's where you you
get megan ma marco and harry well you
know we can't meet trump we won't and it
just seems pathetic it doesn't seem
noble it doesn't seem virtual to me
refusing to meet trump seems pretty
noticeable
it does but it's the moment you start
picking and choosing which difficult
world leaders you're not going to meet
then you're making much of the world
so you'd have putin on this show would
you yes absolutely that
but like wouldn't you think hold on a
minute he's committing no i think hold
on a minute i'm going to ask you some
tough questions in fact don't you think
that there's something more significant
we should do than ask him a personal
question with a pen don't you think we
should actually actually right now i'm
about to interview official spokesman
for the taliban are you saying i
shouldn't be doing that well i'm not
sure that i mean sure if you're going to
absolutely nail them if you're going to
give them a space to expound them if you
want to give their opinions yes stand
back and i'll do it hell yeah
don't ask me twice i will do what i
always do which is i will ask the
questions i think people want to have
answered but i don't see any reason why
i wouldn't interview vladimir putin or
why i wouldn't interview my next guest
which is the official spokesman for the
taliban it's only final question is this
country ready for the queen passing
because it's going to be such an
enormous
i don't think we're ever going to be
ready because i think she's an
impossible act to follow and i think
that king charles iii and king william
the fourth
will never be and could never mean what
she means to the people because she goes
right right back to the second world war
she goes right back to that i mean you
said last night on this show um you know
there's never been a time when she
wasn't on the throne i'm 10 years older
than you and there's never been a time
you look about 10 years younger by the
way
that's his boxing training we've got
lennox lewis on there dude
he'll be keen on your training regime
because you you never get any older
thank you for coming on i appreciate it
thank you very much tony great to see
you again you'll enjoy this next segment
uh tony it's a little moment of dog dog
glove which i know you'll love uh talk
about heart stopping this is the moment
a woman's beloved pet dog
suddenly jumped or maybe fell out of a
window and it was captured by a doorbell
camera so we can see it rachel green
from kent and the southern victim was on
a doorstep talking to a tradesman when
she suddenly noticed an upstairs window
open she only saw it because the
sunlight's reflection against the wall
caught her eye the next thing she knew a
beloved dog was hurtling
towards potential death see what
happened
he's got his own stuff
oh my god get back
oh my god
oh my god
tony and i both ask for fans i mean i
like aaron ramsey our keeper but we
could do with erin gold against
tottenham on thursday uh from a dog
that's lucky to be alive to one that's
actually saving lives president
zielenski is awarded a mind-sniffing dog
called patron a medal for services to
ukraine the dog has helped find more
than 200 devices during the war has also
become something of a national hero and
a symbol of canine ukrainian resistance
what um patron we're all very proud of
you